okay four people joining us we are
continuing right on the tail of another
meeting we are going into our language
completeness and consistency meeting
looking at various of language features
looks like a comparator famous last
words it looks like a comparatively
short agenda today um okay that's some
and and you want to be running in a
recent prototype build if you want to
evaluate things okay okay should I bring
up this notebook in the prototype build
I don't think you have to okay okay
valid arguments Q thanks let's do it
what is it doing so these are these are
things you approved of apparently
forgotten our argument checking
functions and there's a a future ice
draft page although I'm discovering that
it's hard to sort of write the
documentation and I sort of explain why
but there in that notebook and also in
separate arguments has sort of
so this doesn't evaluate arguments now
this is highly relevant to Christopher's
project so what is the use for the
implications there are examples of
returning unev alyou ated right you went
right by them yeah they're so wait a
minute so this is a thing it doesn't
evaluate these arguments it's
essentially doing metaprogramming
looking structurally at that object
mm-hmm and seeing whether right sorry we
have always had some internal functions
that we use to check whether the number
of arguments is correct any so this is
the idea of promoting those functions to
system and this also checks option names
for functions that have options okay
what separate arguments it's the it
separates the it returns a list or
possibly another head where it returns a
list of the of the sort of the
positional arguments followed by a list
of the options flattened so I you know
it's somewhat less useful but there are
styles of programming that you know that
for which this is useful so it's
included and sort of underneath they're
basically the same function right one
basically just returns the arguments and
the other just turns that into a
predicate so how would this work in the
confirm and closed world of checking
well it's I mean this is slightly
orthogonal um no I mean I think what
wouldn't see the thing that I'm I'm
confused by is you would end up with
something which says confirm test of
expert comma valid arguments Q of X / or
whatever is f of X Y Z oh great okay
we're talking about a function called
valid arguments Q which is a
standardization of argument checking
that takes an unavailing ssin and checks
whether its argument structure is
correct okay so it's like okay yeah I
mean there's like a kernel function that
basically does this right so then the
then the idea would be that in the
confirm in closed world you would have
things like this all over the place that
right possibly I mean depends on whether
you want or turn a failure object or if
you want to just issue a message and
return on the value right like i mean i
think i think you're right i mean the
most common case for this is probably
going to be okay for example the case
where this is used in kernel code the
usual behaviors issue an automatic
message will automatically say
such-and-such called with n arguments
and or and you know arguments are
expected right and then and then it
returns unev alyou ated so so this
returns a message by default this is a
message returning function this is a
function that right very odd for a cue
function and a message returning
function but this is it doesn't return a
message it issues whether it's a
side-effect
I mean maybe maybe this is kind of
analogous like what assert does where it
prints a message right so I mean maybe
maybe I don't know maybe Q is not the
right name but I don't know and well
it's still a q function because it
returns true or false it has it has the
convenient I claim and and obviously
most of us clean side-effect of issuing
the message that you want the function
to issue because it's the way of
centralizing arguments checking so that
people don't have to invent that
themselves okay so so what would the
typical piece of code look like right
would it be I mean with the typical
piece of code say f of X blank why blank
colon equals blah blah blah slash some a
valid arguments q f of XY it's kind of
grotesquely you have to repeat the F of
XY and the alternative I suppose would
be to say you know e : f of X Y blank
there fell arguments of e which would
that work that works i I've started
doing that use it use that right and
that you I mean the more common use case
actually is f of XY equals blah and then
f of you know no blank sequence equals
valid arguments to you what about this
would this work sure I know exciting the
precedents for question yeah I mean what
in the parentheses but yes that would
work so that slum what bizarrely it
would look like what it looked like
no the Q yeah and I and I don't think
you want X comma Y now I think you want
args triple underscore if you already
know that it's got to all right I mean
right it'll need to be a pure function
right because you'll need to write so I
see you saying well we could have up we
could have a curried in an operator form
of this valid arguments to
of three hey even that you need
parentheses pressing a question mark is
higher than brackets yep yeah yeah that
grotesque I mean that's a that's a
slightly it slightly weird you need the
parentheses but but although we could
have the CODIS system system warned you
not not in a grotesque piece of code
right except that I don't think that'll
actually work right because this needs
to hold its arguments right this this
function is hold first right so unless
you write this is just going to recurse
great okay so only the pattern slashes
that make it so but this would work yep
yeah because if you specify the argument
count yeah because the l-value mechanism
knows that : isn't isn't to be included
in the old value it knows right yes it's
because our option it's because pattern
has higher precedence than set right yes
I understand that but it isn't setting a
pattern on patterns I mean sorry it
isn't setting an assignment for pattern
it's setting an assignment for F still
yes that's a common thing though like
this this is not a super unusual
structure especially for sub values like
this is very useful when you're if you
have like a data type or something and
then you wanted to find lots of sub
values for it then really often you want
to be able to say you know you know
whatever your object is D :
that object of such and such and then
that way you can say D of and then give
it another sub values right sub bodies
in terms of others some values okay I
mean this is the up values mechanism
which was different so that's okay okay
great
all right time I'm go ahead though so
maybe another use of this
is you know sometimes people write like
you know you write all of your patterns
for the different usages and then you
write like a catch-all pattern at the
end you know where you say you know F
those expert triple underscore and then
you know one lazy thing that you can do
is you know you throw a message that
just says Oh something you know the
arguments are not the right structure
but that's that's kind of bad it's not
very specific
so another usage this might be in that
catch-all case where you would just
write you know valor arguments q of you
know e
you know semicolon and maybe do some
other tests and then if all of those
fail they don't return a message then
you can give a final kind of you know a
final kind of general message I don't
know that might be another use case well
but what do you set this equal to I mean
is it equal from this well yes or
whatever right the value doesn't matter
right because you're going to have a
parenthesis and a semicolon false
they're right this is assuming you want
to return on evaluated right if you want
it if you want to turn a failure object
or something you know yes
you'd have to do something else and it's
assuming you actually covered all the
other cases oh yeah you'd absolutely
need like a catch-all case at the end so
so you'd say valor argument q of
whatever and you know whatever other
tests you have and they'd say and
message the general message semicolon
false right or something like that yeah
it's a little weird right yeah so some
people do that - yeah right so they open
parenthesis right and either you do
semicolon while you can do semicolon
false and closed parenthesis at the end
of the valid arguments q right and so
this is okay you didn't match any of my
main patterns so I'm going to issue a
message about invalid arguments here
that's a common idiom and then if there
are other ways you might possibly fail
then you might have you know and after
the valid arguments q to issue other
message
if there are cases where you can return
unevaluated for other reasons a little
bit not perfect but this is better than
what people are doing right now
yes um right so if you open up the
separate arguments which I admit is the
less useful but I have sort of
discussion in there about why it's so
hard to write good documentation for
this is it not no no no there we go
right so we have right we have right
there and actually I also mentioned this
in the agenda that we have sort of four
different things we have sort of all
arguments which is everything we have
options which are the rule like things
that go into option value personally I
would recommend saying argument rules of
the expression turn an association that
says positional I don't know arrow blah
blah maybe you want also : greater than
because maybe the function is no hold
all or something like that right yeah
yeah it's gonna be yeah I mean you
probably still be optional head there's
an optional there's there's an option
where you can change the head of to a
list of no no it's not not head so
there's an option to the function that
changes if you look at head there that
changes the
from list so you can make it hold so you
cannot sure well but so in that case
though if you if you set that to hold so
it doesn't return a list of holds it
returns just a big hold right correct
okay um it seems like the only the only
things you really ever want to use our
our hold and hold it complete right I
mean otherwise right yeah well I mean
there are I mean I can conceive of cases
where it might be handy because you have
your own custom holding construct in
your body of code that might be useful
but as a general rule yes hold and hold
complete are the natural other values
than lists for right for this yeah I
guess I guess yeah you're right I mean
there's also even stuff like inactivate
you might use or actually know and
activate I don't think a spare args
button yeah exactly because I think in
cases where I've used the non system
version of this I frequently use as my
head you're sort of a function that is
you know has the appropriate hold
attributes that is then going to sort of
immediately proceed to do things so I
sort of cut out a middle step in the
process I see so that's an application
to this um okay so I mean but one
approach here will be to have an
argument rules thing where the second
argument to argument rules could be a
string name which extracts just that
particular feature or you get the whole
Association and then extract from it
well I mean you still need well I guess
we could have that optional I guess it
would be an optional third or fourth
argument right because we still need the
the other arguments there right we can't
right.you there's no such thing as
positional and optional if you don't say
how many positional arguments there can
be right so at a minimum you need two
arguments and they believe or the
current separate arguments takes two or
three oh okay well we could also have an
association there that has more
information about this function they
will be nice wouldn't it to be able to
share that block of information between
argument rules and the syntax cholera
and things like this possibly
[Music]
what is the story we're currently with a
syntax cholera and how does that relate
to valid arguments q well they well
certainly valid arguments q checks way
more things than the syntax color can
check for one thing it can check for
hidden options that okay fine but if I'm
trying to set up a function and I want
two things I want the valid argument
message and I want the and I want syntax
coloring how do I achieve that I'm sorry
I was
a little coughing fit and so I didn't
actually hear your question so I'm
saying if I want to achieve two things
I'm defining a user-defined function
I wanted to syntax color and I wanted to
have valid argument messages how do I
achieve that there you create the
aptly-named not yet existing function
that would set the syntax information
and I guess set up a default rule that
issues messages for any okay stuff I
mean is is there another thing where we
say something like set
I mean is there yet another function
here you know something like set valid
arguments of F comma blah blah blah go
ahead could we do that should we write
the right I mean so we could do that I
think and it would right I mean it would
the the only limitation would be is that
well if there aren't options if there
aren't options basically the user would
have to write sort of like there
wouldn't be and so the basic issue is
suppose we did this and we set up the
default rule that issued that message
there would be the the user if they had
any cases that didn't match but we're
still correct options they would have to
somehow issue those messages themselves
there are patterns I mean right so
suppose not every to argue say suppose
you said set valid arguments of F 2 2
but then if you just wrote f of XY
equals stuff and that always evaluated
then that's fantastic but
if there's a case where that didn't
evaluate then you would just fall down
and you would never issue a message
because you did have the correct number
of arguments which maybe is fine
maybe that's we don't care about that
case but okay hold on that what is the
story with the syntax coloring stuff set
syntax information or whatever it's
called yep syntax information yeah so I
mean that's by the way another model so
so there's there's maybe two versions of
this which is you know one version is
you sort of do something like the will
you're doing before where you sort of
just give it some sort of kind of
arbitrary pure function or something
like that and it runs those and it does
those tests and so on and maybe you want
to make some functions like this valid
arguments commuted sort of are the
functions that you would give it the
other version is something more like
syntax information which is more rigid
but maybe also a bit easier to use which
is where you just sort of give it you
know a list of rules or an association
or something that just gives it you know
you have a set number of keys where you
just say number of arguments or you know
options or whatever and then it just
sort of works from there okay so hold on
a second number of I mean so this I
don't quite understand why syntax
information syntax information is what
does this do what why I mean so this
syntax information if I say arguments
pattern two to five and I give seven
arguments it will have nothing to do
with the evaluation it will not force it
to return an evaluated when it's an out
of range number of arguments is that
true correct but typically the patterns
will just so I see so the generation of
a message for that case one could
imagine could be included in syntax
information that for example one could
say you know among these properties one
could say you know arguments message
arrow true right I mean the only thing
is you don't necessarily want that
because for example well maybe this is a
different problem but there are some
functions that
you know they might have an undocumented
third argument for example or all right
and the other problem right is you know
if functions already do their own
checking if this is adding a random down
value to accomplish this then that's a
problem
and how does rules mode get incorporated
how does what rules
well roads mode isn't really relevant to
what is it it's it's one of the options
of valid arguments queue and separate
arguments about how how to treat rule
lists of rules and rules list of rules
and lists thereof and when because if
you have if you don't have a fixed
number of of arguments and you have
rules in those optional argument
positions you may not know whether those
are to be treated as positional
arguments or as options allow an
arbitrary pattern here if I say no no it
is precisely those those those patterns
that are documented and in the notes
there otherwise the front end will
assert and sadness will ensue okay but
we could also then have another optional
way to set this which is just something
about argument count doesn't really make
any difference that's a I don't
understand we are multi counting here I
mean by by having this valid argument
skew as well as syntax information it
seems like we're doing the same thing
twice perhaps the idea would be that if
you specify the second argument of valid
argument skew it comes here and see what
are the valid numbers well that's
interesting
so you're saying valid arguments Q see
but to me they're a bum right but again
there are arguments future
swaye more than syntax information ever
could sure I'm just trying to connect it
both functions all right but I'm saying
I don't fit but I don't saying it's not
an either/or which is what Stephen was
trying to argue well okay I guess but
that's three things that go on okay
there's cut syntax coloring there's
actual argument enforcement and thus
generating a message by argument
enforcement I mean forcing a you know
even in a triple blank situation forcing
an unavailing return mm-hmm okay there's
a three separate or not somewhat
orthogonal things I think and I like
Jose's idea of using syntax information
as the sort of automatic setting for
valid arguments q that seems sensible to
me whether valid arguments Q needs to
jump I mean generating a message from
valid arguments q seems kind of weird to
me otherwise it's just length right the
whole point of it is it's it's a lot
more than just length right because it
checks option names and etc but but yes
I agree that the default should be to
issue messages now if you want to argue
that there's a mode where it doesn't
issue messages maybe but you could just
as equally quiet it if you wanted that
mode for some reason but account
messages are there what's that is that
how many are count messages are there at
least eight possibly more right there
was one of the most useful things in
this function that is you see the right
argument misses
okay Ardex Artie Artie you okay okay
okay but what about putting something
into syntax information which says if
it's wrong generate a message on
evaluation or you say basically since I
conformation shouldn't mess with the
evaluation semantics syntax of
information isn't I mean the what syntax
information stores isn't used at
evaluation time that that is what I was
wondering I had never heard of syntax
information and just looking at the
documentation I expect it to be for the
front end I don't expect it to be used
by the kernel well based on
documentation you're correct
I mean I think it's also that's the name
syntax information tells you this is
this has nothing to do with actual
evaluation right and by the way is
somebody doing this for the function
repository or they are they setting
syntax information for those functions I
think so because I mean right the way
are the way system functions get their
syntax information is that there's a
pass through the documentation notebooks
that translates those usage messages
into syntax information I don't think
it's happening for the function
repository right now and it really
should so good I wonder if the fact that
it's a compound head and not just a
symbol it's maybe I user assistance so
Devon you yeah could you take that to
those guys yes ask what's going on I
haven't seen that on the user user
assistance agenda we should livestream
some user assistance meetings that kind
of interesting um I mean this is sort of
general but it seems like maybe we just
need some sort of more general function
for sort of declaring when you want to
make like a you know a proper function
in the sense like if you're writing a
package right and you have lots of
little internal functions that are
basically just you know colon equals etc
but then sometimes you also are like
writing quotes a proper function that's
to be exported where you want usage
lines you want syntax information you
want proper you know messages and stuff
like that you want attributes exactly
and you basically just want to set all
of these things because right now you
have to you know write many different
lines did you reach of these right and
Steven you may not recall because the
this you know the meeting where we last
discussed this was certainly over a year
ago but basically you approved these two
functions as you know separate steps to
be part of the super function that
Christopher is describing so we talked
about having a super function but also
having these Moore's because certainly
we use I mean so separate arguments is
basically a cleaned up version of system
private arguments and system private
arguments with rules which you know
we've been using internally for a decade
and lots and lots of people use them so
there's certainly useful functions but I
think you know like I said we're we're
I'm and I think and if you want to add
the automatic behavior looking at syntax
information I don't have a problem with
that actually all right but the the
where we're falling down is is writing
the documentation and I mentioned this
in the agenda there that we have these
for things like all of the parts we have
options we have arguments which you know
are the things which are not options and
then sort of optional arguments and and
which is two separate arguments which I
which I don't name of I mean what's
wrong with my argument rules suggestion
I you know I I have I think I think we
can do that it's it's just a minor
refactoring the problem like I said and
that's fine I'm happy to rename it that
and but the problem is have how do we
talk about these four things in a non
confusing manner what are we talking
about them for
well for one thing the well just read
the first usage message and then there
are places in examples or for you know
describing what rules mode does okay
what's wrong with that first thing
separate I mean okay generate argument
rules generates a list of rules
describing the arguments augs
I was just about to mention rules seems
to suggest a list of rules not an
association I know but we've had that
unfortunately we've been using this term
rules well most of those functions are
our folder functions that actually do
useless rules
I mean maybe music the word information
argument information there was a problem
with that if syntax information sounds
it sounds more advisory unless I guess
it is advisory well it suggests more
like meta information about the
arguments okay yeah no argument
information is actually knew you'd want
you'd expect that to be the analogous
thing to syntax information you say
argument information of F equals and
then you give it some rights right and
and I mean if you want to understand the
purpose I mean you can again go to the
applications area you know I wouldn't
say this is and this is an idiom that
people use so we're supporting it but
I'm not sure it's the most important
which one oh do we not have fun of these
I thought we did right but basically all
right so I guess this is a yeah right so
we separated into the args and options
and then we'd sort of do a switch on the
length of our glist to sort of you
or sometimes they have separate down
values for horrible I mean why aren't
people using options patent they are
using options pattern but you see that
doesn't work in exactly the case of n of
the last of varargs on being the rule
because then it gets included as an
invalid up as the first invalid option
instead of being included in the
arguments I thought the options pattern
looked at the option names no perhaps it
should well I think I think of it it
sees well I think the point is that it's
looking at the the last argument and
saying this is not a valid option but
maybe if it's just right because because
it has to like if I just gave a single
it kind of has to do that because
otherwise if I just have plot and I give
you know some broken option is the first
well I guess plot isn't bare Arg so it
knows but yeah right right that the kona
the canonical example of this for which
the for what's the arguments with rules
variant that has become an option on
valid arguments q is was string trim I
think our sorry string split because the
second argument is optional and can be
not just a string expression but a
replacement rule and then people ran
into the problem that yep you just have
to really hope it doesn't have any
options like string of five names it's
that right that's one of the things and
and how does it choose whether whether
you meant to specify an option or
whether you meant to specify sorry
coming back to options pattern does
options pattern check the left hand side
of fugitive of potential options against
the list of options for that head it
can't do that because if it did that and
therefore failed to match then you
wouldn't enter the down value to issue
the message that an invalid option was
supplied it was gonna say it depends on
how you call options or options pattern
well no no it does not depend because
you can specify a function
to consult for its options in option
pattern but that doesn't affect which
options are matched that affects how
they are you know what default values
they get and also that's that's how
option value issues the message that
there was an invalid option in the in
the list of option queue things that
match the options Pataca I have a
suggestion
what if maybe this is crazy what if
there was something in patterns that was
a wrapper that says if this doesn't
match generate a message other words
you're trying to match something so I
could I could say you know mismatched
message of why blank Zee blank okay so
that pattern then becomes what the heck
is that why is there because of the
center because you declared syntax
information but I got rid of it I said
syntax information of F equals blank how
do I get rid of it I don't think you can
because I don't think there's a way to
the signal to the front end
try setting it to an empty list quack
this is gotta work I mean that's
completely crazy to try making it try
again I mean there you gotta give it a
chance to write the bracket again it's
only gonna check the syntax when you're
typing I think no the blame Shawn faults
right we have we have I I cannot control
what the front end colors are not okay
you're all about just as it I did I did
I just tried that why is it black
try remove a bat okay try any arguments
pattern goes empty list I did
arguments pattern here no that's just a
hackle oh I think that would expect zero
guys separate problem let's figure out
how and document how you remove syntax
information it's completely right equals
dot should remove it but it looks like
it's probably a bug right I mean if you
try writing syntax information of asked
does it return what does it return it
should return right right then if you
and if you clear it if you unset it
presumably it drew well it might still
return an empty list what happens if you
oh but I just okay
this is the bug okay so let's just you
know report it to front-end team and get
it fixed okay what I'm suggesting though
is that in the pattern matcher that
there be a mechanism to issue a message
if something doesn't match oh let's try
the match and it will be like saying
/semi you know so there's probably some
way to do it with question mark that
would issue a message if it doesn't
match but what how about having a
wrapper that says that so in other words
you would say something like um you know
for the options pattern thing you would
have a wrapper around the options
pattern that says if this I'm not sure
quite sure that's right but it or well
you put something into the options
pattern that says if you try to match an
it doesn't work if there is no way to
match this so first of all I think I
don't know how implementable it is but
second of all I think this is actually
the wrong my point of view is actually
that this is solving the wrong problem
the wrong problem right I would rather
it actually it not match and then
everything fall through to my you know
default of down value that issues the
messages about you know wrong arguments
and invalid options I say okay
that's not unreasonable that's not a
reasonable point of view so also I'm not
sure it's well defined because you know
options value fails to match because
actually there's this other pattern that
can you know match this etc so I mean I
think yeah I would prefer something like
check arguments rather than a valid
argument skew which suggests a very
clean Q function not something that's
off flapping around and issuing messages
and doing all kinds of other things okay
so I mean it let's say it was called
check arguments and then the thing and
then what you're asking is what are the
then it could either be um I mean I
don't like this term but decompose
arguments is kind of I mean that for the
other one for separate arguments what
about describe arguments I don't use
described by much does it need a first
part could just be arguments use that
okay yeah I I don't know I mean never
mind this I know that we called the
system private version but I just don't
know right until until you read a rough
page arguments just means nothing means
nothing I mean we could call it
arguments Association if we want to do
that yeah I mean that's what I mean a
lot of things are called arguments rules
but I mean I think we have some number
of things which are fool Association
which aren't just things that that
returned that you know may be arguments
association or argument association
arguments I think arguments
what is down values association oh
really so we don't have anything and so
we have association foo for things that
operate on associations but we don't
have anything and maybe I think we do is
like why are we entity it's something
and that some internal context thing
right it's a German utilities yeah right
you've load the general utility
apparently and it's in okay all right
okay fine okay here here's an example
there's a entity association the third
argument for entity value right so
that's a string argument but yes yeah I
think there are a few string arguments
like that go but yeah so that's what I
was thinking of so yes but entity
association then we have we have more of
them even if I can't think of any off
the top of my head but okay so arguments
Association who for some reason
arguments rules just seems more natural
but I don't know why mm-hmm I think it
seems more natural because it's a sort
of low it's a sort of a function that
might have been a really old function
and that sounds like an old function
name and and frankly I mean I think and
frankly I'm you know we could make this
be a list of rules I mean I'm not sure
that we gained that much by having it be
an association right that basically
going to be two keys in it right we do
get something by being an association
because we can index into it I'm more
nicely it's always gonna be two keys
good or not to be a list which is what
it is and it's called right so so if you
don't like separate arguments we could
call it arguments list that's not
terrible or anything you think it's
gonna be the list of yeah exactly
right that's the problem there that this
is not the list of artists well
arguments lists
mm-hmm I mean the other possibility
would be that they'd rather argument
option lists two arguments options list
that's what it is
yeah singular might be better but
argument option
I think that's obscure because I think
it suggests that it could be the option
of the argument and so on yeah I think
arguments options list is clear I'm I'm
fine with that name actually you know
separate arguments from I think was sort
of the least bad name we came up with at
the meeting however many months ago it
was like oh you know what I do I do
really like including the word option in
the function name to make it clear
what's going on mm-hmm yeah
all right so arguments options list is
probably the winner there so let's look
at what it does so it generates a list
of the arguments and options of the
function yep it's pretty much the
correct thing to say and what it's
provided with is the number of things
that should be considered as arguments
yet the first end things should be
considered as arguments how to treat
optional positional arguments what is o
what does that mean so that's the string
split right so so look at the option
values the following values of Rosemont
can be given
I see and the default here should should
presumably be the second one that is
only if it is a valid option of F should
you consider it to be an option I think
I know why you're saying that
but all kernel functions unless
explicitly coded otherwise actually
defaults to the other behavior as some
kind of right you so that way what well
for one thing the issuing right so if
it's right because that way you give a
message about you know an unknown option
rather than it quietly being accepted as
a positional argument mm-hm
I should have to go so goodbye but yeah
so I think it is correct that options is
is the default okay I'm also slightly
losing concentration because I also have
to go soon here I can we such a
different Bryan are asking saying we
should support an official Visual Studio
code plug-in I believe that is actually
in the works we can perhaps look at just
a few examples make sure we're of what
of separate arguments just make sure
we're okay with this wording so
arguments options list
right it's okay to meet for that one I
think that could arguably be that should
be a failure object not $1 failed yeah I
suppose it could be but trying to
because we've got a lot of richer and
richer handling of failure objects say
if it returns a failure object then you
know for purposes of returning unev al
you ated it's more specific than a
generic dollar failed right although I
guess but given that we've already
issued a message I'm not sure what we
gain by duplicating that information and
we don't know because it depends on what
you have how computer well you need to
handle it okay the other possibilities
to return and evaluated here and now
that are too weird I mean well it cannot
do the operation if failure objectives
is fine may also prefer a failure object
to to the office yeah um okay
okay um all right so try and then this
becomes check arguments okay all right
let's let's see whether we can get
Valley Q is one of those incredibly
horrifying functions right and I think
basically what we've done is pretty good
and you can value you know run the
exhibit some future iced exam some
future eyes notes and examples to the
ref page that will evaluate in the
prototype build
right so so I guess they're there well
maybe I'll let you read them oh boy this
would be good to us Christopher about
because he just thought about this in
connection with the confirm evaluates
cue or confirms changes this is a can of
worms let's let's punt this and ask
Christopher because he's just thought
about this okay and we need to make sure
he's in the next one of these meetings
okay
and neither one of the next two are at
all time well maybe the timing function
but that's not a short discussion I
don't think maybe it is I thought we
needed this would just be a method
option or something at the moment in a
code I mean at least it is a method
option so do we were thinking that it in
the same way that there is a distance
function you could have a time extension
yeah I thought we I don't we agreed on
that last time didn't we well there was
not and with this set of people but the
question is whether you know I mean so
echo time as the first bullet point says
right there echo timing has a method
option that can take timing absolute
timing right a timing or an arbitrary
function now repeated timing you know
basically as an app in the absolute
timing family so maybe calling it
repeated timing was maybe well well I
mean it said look the other question is
if you have a timing function what I act
is that a time constraint arrow
seventeen timing function arrow absolute
timing would somehow imply that the time
constraint was on absolute time
look the [ __ ] is this what this
reminds me of and this is an interesting
idea for time constraint okay maybe
there should be a notion of indicating
what kind of a time duration that is and
I think we're gonna have that issue in
the elaborate Astro you know earth
slowing down world and so on and in the
following sense that right so it's it's
like is it CPU timers at wall clock time
is it sidereal time is it time relative
to you know UTC or whatever that making
any sense
and in other words there's different
notions of what I mean
CPU time is like timing based on
rotations of the earth I think here we
have the difference between time and
timing so time has a time system which
is UTC or sidereal time or whatever
timing is always in seconds no but I'm
saying timing is the analog of the
computational problem for the physical
case is timing is how many times did the
earth rotate how many cycles of the CPU
were gone through that CPU time or earth
rotation time as opposed to absolute
inexorable time in the evolution of the
universe if you believe in such things
which I don't but they're the the
absolute inexorable time of the universe
right only local observers with their
light clocks have have a notion of time
right well yeah absolutely time yes that
that's well there's a cosmological rest
frame but but we're gonna get way off
track here no I mean you're correct that
that's a but the difference between I
mean oh boy this this this
you know slides back into you know I
finally have a quantity which is
actually the the it's a it's in the
hierarchy that starts with speed of
light
then it's this maximum entanglement
speed and then the next and final
constant in that sequence is something
which is the maximum speed of
translating between two different rule
systems for the universe which is in the
units of which basically gives you the
underlying absolute processing speed of
the universe and its units I just wrote
a post about this it's units are Wolfram
language tokens per second
I mean it could be it could be Turing
machine tokens per second but it has to
have units just like meters per second
it has to have units of computational
specification per second mm-hmm okay but
this is yeah just a jump back to this I
think I think Jose's point which I agree
with is that timing is a quantity
whereas time is a position on you know
on some sort of reference frame well so
absolute time if we went across a leap
second what would happen to it absolute
time would be the the time difference
taking out that leap second so in other
words my my computation might actually
have taken a negative amount of absolute
time if it's spanned a leap second so
the plan is to introduce a time system
option in date object and it will play
the role of datums in deal in the same
way that the calendar plays the role of
projections the separation right so not
actually knowing how things really work
at a hardware or os level I would claim
that absolute timing is always
non-negative because it's going to be
right than numb you know the reading on
the CMOS clock or something at the end -
the the reading on the CMOS clock at the
beginning irrespective of what that's
not going to be correct because because
the amount TP server whatever it is that
you know the network Time
whatever that's cool mm-hmm will reset
you know in other words the mapping to
UTC right so right so then I might over
count right if I suppose if it went
backwards it could potentially be
negative I'm barely 2 seconds which way
around to the leap set I mean the earth
is slowing down so there must right
seconds I guess that's because the earth
is not speeding up there can be leap
seconds only there are only added
seconds right not right it could happen
that it is pizza so so it's it's a it's
an average that's slowing down but it
can it could happen it's just that it
hasn't happened in the last 50 years yes
but this is you know in in in you know
silly whatever they are you know if
everybody if all the 7 billion people on
the earth run in one direction at the
same time it'll have absolutely no
effect no it's in relation to the
protocol so when there is a leap second
different computers do different things
so some of them that day they can spread
that second during the whole day and
others they simply repeat the last
second so so 23:59 of 60 actually
happens twice Wow
I see so there's a moment at which the
synchronization is broken for the
computers of the earth exactly yes in a
sense the problem of what to do with
timing would be different from there
what to do with time and I know what to
do with time because we will have the
tables or one second was added here so
every time we do a computation we would
have to take that into account but what
to do with absolute I mean I don't know
because that will depend on their
infrastructure in the computer right at
which point I think we you know maybe
the answer is we just live with whatever
the OS does and if somebody's really
unlike unlucky they might get an extra
second or lose
second and they're at their absolute I
can just imagine in some piece of code
somewhere something going incredibly
wrong if it goes across a leap second
and the absolute time is negative mm-hmm
I mean I bet whether we didn't talk
about that as possible issues than the
absolute timing stuff but because we
don't have this time datums yes it's the
distance that screwed up when the price
of oil went negative a few weeks ago I
was thinking of the old joke of the
programmer who wakes up in the year 9999
and everybody's ecstatic because we they
see on their resume that they know kubal
right so instead of the year 2000 they
have the year 10,000 issue oh yes okay
fair enough
the PM I didn't know didn't cobol have
it have a two-digit issue doesn't have a
four-digit earnest you I I don't know I
think it's just now it does was the code
rewritten or is it running in a virtual
machine that had a time reset
who knows and I think there are
mainframes that have been in continuous
operation since some time in the 60s
and I doubt that they had software
upgrades mm-hmm okay well anyway uh so
as you say it's a slightly more
complicated discussion
all right let's wrap it up here then um
okay all right thanks a lot oh um let's
see tomorrow what's happening why am I
being told to remind people about
upcoming live streams oh okay their
parent Li yeah the couple on Friday
neural nets and science and technology
Q&A all right okay well thanks everybody
talk to you all soon